the trooper cabra a mysterious creature
common in Latin American folklore with
its first sightings been reported in
Puerto Rico during the mid 90s the
chupacabra developed the reputation when
livestock began mysteriously dying the
animals were found completely drained of
blood
through a small circular fang-like
incision according to experts at the
time these incisions could not be from
any known animal of the region there
were more than 200 reports of the
chupacabra being seen in 1995 alone
the creature became an urban legend all
over South America but as quickly as
these sightings began they stopped with
no trace leaving a host of questions the
named trooper cabra translated in
Spanish roughly means goat sucker
referring to how the creature attacks
its prey
the appearance of the chupacabra varies
drastically some claim the animal is the
size of a small bear and others believe
it is no bigger than a wolf in most
depictions it has rows of spines that
run from the base of its neck to its
tail the Beast has razor-sharp teeth or
vampire-like fangs
along with draining the blood of its
victims it is sometimes depicted as
having wings similar to that of a bat
meaning that people consider the
chupacabra to be a vampire like beasts
there have been claims from local
villages that the trooper cabra is a
large reptilian like creature who is
able to walk on two legs as the
chupacabra has become such a widespread
legend there are varying reports of the
creature strengths and weaknesses the
chupacabras bite contains a strong venom
allowing them to stun their victims
while they feed on them its bites may
even be considered contagious in fact in
anyone its fangs come into contact with
turning them into a chupacabra
the chupacabra can overpower large
animals and even sometimes humans rip in
their flesh from their bones with ease
there are reports that claim the
chupacabra has the ability of hypnosis
it is believed that anything that stares
into its red eyes will become paralyzed
leaving them motionless while the
Chupacabra feeds thanks to its wings and
web joints the creature is able to glide
long distances make an escape for its
prey almost impossible despite its vast
array of strengths there are ways to
kill a chupacabra many believe much like
a vampire
the chupacabra has a strong aversion to
the Sun meaning that direct sunlight
will kill the creature it is also
believed that guns can harm the
chupacabra
with the shotgun being preferred as the
wide spread of the buckshot makes it
impossible for the chupacabra to
regenerate similar to sunlight fire can
burn the chupacabra and is thought to be
a useful tool and trying to repel the
Beast
there were many conspiracy theories as
to where the chupacabra came from the
most popular being that it was
engineered in the lab by NASA when
experimenting on guerrillas in Chile
NASA quickly denied this theory
comparing it to that of the fake moon
landing conspiracy even with most of the
trooper Cobra attacks being explained as
a breed of wild dog there are people who
believe that it was something else
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you if you have
anything you'd like to discuss or have
any ideas for future videos then please
go ahead and let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explained